Hey guys, how's it going?
So today we're gonna be chatting about something that I've had in my possession for like... weeks!
So a lot of you guys know one of the biggest things that
was a disappointment with the new MacBooks, is the charger is now just straight up USB-C.
Previous MacBooks,
you had this thing called MagSafe.
Which is actually quite funny a lot of people didn't know that that was because it was magnetic.
I-I know. I think I made mention of that and I was actually quite surprised
How many people in the comments were like,
Wow, I guess that does make sense. So with that if you bumped your computer, or you tripped over the charging cable,
You wouldn't completely entirely lose your computer to the floor so far, knock on,
Absolutely everything! I have yet to have that happen to me. I-I so,
Oh God, I'm putting it out there! The universe,
I'm sorry!
I have not had very good Apple luck! Shattered phones and my sister got her MacBook stolen!
So this is the Griffin breakaway cable. This can also be used on USB-C phones.
Basically just turns to USB-C into MagSafe.
And that's why I can't ever return anything.
So there's two ends on this little guy. There's one that has the little MagSafe- USB-C end.
You'll also have this little USB-C dongle which you can just put into your computer. Does it work? Yes.
Do you need it? No.
Do you want it? Probably.
Huh, it's pretty long. It's nice.
The cable's kind of stiff though,
which I feel like most of the USB-C cables are.
So the upside is, this will save your computer-
If you happen to trip over it. The downside is you need this, and if you lose this magnetic little dongle then...
Good luck!
It's on there pretty good, actually!
No matter which way you pull it,
It's coming off.
This is- this is like that game!
Where you pick up the fish- the magnetic fish. Has anybody played the game when you're younger or now?
Oh yeah that's nice!
That's-that's good!
That's quality!
Cool, well I don't really have anything else to say I mean, it's a magnetic USB-C cable so what else can I tell you?
Well, it looks like on Amazon, it is
$30 they drop the price it used to be $39.99
Which is probably what I payed
because I ordered it so long ago
I like it a lot, and I'm probably going to travel with it and stay tuned for
How long will it take Justine to lose this- episode. Because that will probably be coming up; that will make a video about it.
Stay tuned on Twitter!
Thank you guys so much for watching!
Let me know in the comments below if there's anything else that you think I should check out or you'd like me to check out,.
Or even let me know something
that you absolutely hate.
and you think I should check it out because I feel like I always do positive reviews-
I don't necessarily like to review things if I don't like it, so I feel like in 2017
I think I want to show you guys some things that I hate, maybe don't hate maybe it's just something that disappointed you,
Maybe you expected it to do something, and it didn't I don't know
I'm up for suggestions. But, I'll see you guys later.
Bye!
Boy, it's a really good video.
This was back when it was still stop-motion.
Wha- these are so stupid.
These are so dumb!
Playing Call of Duty.